the dominant way to advertise is not
super high production value
finely produced uh content it's what we
call selfie content right
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right let's do it we're here what's
going on
what's up man um
okay you want to jump in a little bit of
chit chat how you ought to do it
i want to tell you a quick story so our
friend um can we the the guy who emailed
hotels and asked for discounts can we
name him or not no
okay um well he he's our friend he
emailed hotels for a european trip and
he got some crazy good deals he got like
a three thousand dollar room for like
so i'm in new york i need a place to
stay from september first is september
25th i made a list of 20 hotels and i
emailed them
and these hotels probably would cost me
maybe 15 to 20 000 for that period so
like a thousand dollars a night i'm
getting some at like 350 bucks four
hundred dollars a night it's working
that's what's the what's the gist of the
email
i have something that's unfair so
i say hey my name is sam parr
um
i am in town for three months but i need
a place to stay from september first
september 21st i need a relatively big
room because i record this podcast
called my first million and we have
about uh i say like a million listeners
a month and we record it with video so i
need it to look really nice i also write
this daily email that goes out to two
million people and so like i need a
comfortable place to work for my home
right uh my budget is 350 tonight can
you help me
and uh and that works so uh why aren't
they giving to you for free bro that's
big influence or you should be
getting it for free
i don't know i i i'm happy to pay for i
don't want to be a total mooch i just
want a discount
it's not mooching you're you're going to
give them a shout right
whoever you catch no i won't i wouldn't
give them a shout out just because they
get me a place to stay i would only give
me do you shout people out because they
get i mean i get given stuff all the
time and when people give me stuff and
they and then they ask for a shout out i
i say you know f off yeah actually the
other day um
there's a company that i'm using their
product so i reached out to him i was
like hey
uh i can name it i can i think i can
name i think this should be fine so
so basically i use this thing called
passport uh it's like international
shipping company so you'll say you have
a brand you want to ship products to
france or uk or australia or whatever
each country has its own little problems
with shipping with customs with uh tax
with uh you know finding the right
carrier to get a low low shipping cost
there all that so these guys take care
of it so i'm like oh this is a great
product great idea so i emailed um
the ceo alex and i was like hey man like
uh this is great we're gonna use it but
how do i invest also uh
he's like oh like you know we're not
really raising around right now and i
was like please and he was like is it
you know what like um i think you've
already been pretty helpful because you
made some intros i think you can do some
more i think you can do more
uh he's like i don't want to fuss with
paperwork like honestly it's just a big
headache how about i just give you some
free shares and i was like i was like ah
perfect like that's amazing because it's
like a legit company it's not like oh
here's advisor shares in my no name no
revenue no user company like this is a
real company
and it's a very small amount but
i was like he's so smart because he you
sent me an email he goes hey dude
excited to have you on board just signed
us to return it he goes here's kind of
my expectations like what would make
this a win for me
is a b and c
and um they're all like totally
reasonable requests but he just made it
clear what he wants and i was like dude
you couldn't have paid me to do these
things but just by giving me something
free i feel the need to reciprocate by
like over delivering on this for you i
would rather
in retrospect i would rather just buy my
shares and not have any obligations but
uh cool i'm glad we did it this way this
is gonna be more fun and
ultimately smart move by you
so that's called the law or reciprocity
so um there's been a lot of studies on
this and if you read the book
influenced by robert ciaodini it's a uh
it's basically been proven through a lot
of different stuff studies so a great
example is if we're next door neighbors
and i say hey uh
uh sean here you know i i had i ordered
pizza and they gave me two here's an
extra one if you'd like right uh okay so
i did something for you i gave you
something the next day i go hey mike i
don't have a car can i borrow your car
for an hour you are actually incredibly
likely to let me borrow the car even
though those two favors are not at all
equal right in order to make like this
rule works regardless of if they're
equal or not it just if someone owes you
one you want to pay them back in some
capacity and you'll do it in the first
possible chance you have so it's
actually a great rule and when i used to
buy stuff so when i would buy cars i
would always come with two i wrote a
blog post i would come with two cans of
coke and i would have one like
hey uh i you know they had a sale
and they had a sale do you you want you
thirsty was them a drink and uh i would
get discounts like that through buying
stuff
dude that's great that's like the coke
can hack is awesome uh yeah i actually
now i'm so like
aware of it that i have to fight my
inner tendency to want free so like
if somebody wants to send me something
i'm like not only do i not want to give
out my address anymore i'm just like
i don't want to feel like i need to
reciprocate anything to you so like it's
it's actually not worth it for me to
take these things uh like this is
different because i think this company
is going to be really big and i really
respect the the founder but uh but now
i'm like somebody hands me that diet
coke no no thank you sir uh right like i
i it's not like
it's not like i think they're trying
anything it's just i don't wanna have
any uh on my inner balance sheet i don't
wanna have any debts i only want assets
on that in my internal boundaries
i completely agree i do the exact same
thing if someone offered or if they
offered me something and i do want it
for example someone sent me something
for my dog because his hips were hurting
and i was like just you know i'm not
going to give you a shout out if i if i
think things like life-changing i'll
talk about it just casually but like in
no way are you you're just doing me
you're getting this is a gift
not a a payment
exactly um all right so let's uh let's
jump into some ideas or some topics what
do you want to talk about i want to talk
to you about a couple things um i want
you to teach me about something that did
do you want to talk about this two
things friends with benefits are you
prepared to discuss that yeah yeah we
could talk about it
because this is your realm but this is
it's totally your world but it's the
first time i've seen something
in this space that actually interests me
um and i think exactly it's like well
okay so
first explain what it is and then i'll
tell you but basically and i'll tell you
why i'm interested but basically it's
like
uh uh
the first time i've seen this technology
used in a useful way that isn't just
gimmicky
right yeah yeah okay i know what you
mean and ironically this is the one that
i think
i'm interested but i'm like i don't
really get it and then i like move on so
so it's cool we're on the other end of
this okay so what is this friends with
benefits is a it's basically a community
it's a membership club
that was created by this guy in la
that um
you know he was he was the co-founder of
a company called brood and they they
make little michaela that instagram
influencer who's just like a digital
avatar it's like looks like a kind of
looks like a real girl but like clearly
it's kind of digital and so they're
using like disney pixar style technology
to make influencers on instagram that's
the company so he creates friends with
benefits he's basically like all right
this is like a digital
soho house basically we're gonna invite
only cool people
uh in and you basically buy the friends
with benefit token in order to enter so
you buy this token called fwb
and uh so there's a million fwb out
there and you buy in in order to get
access to the to the met to the club
which is basically just a discord group
right it's not like there's nothing
there's no physical place to go there's
no like
perks or discounts or whatever it's
basically it's literally like you get to
go into our discord and talk to other
members here
and um
and so they were selling this thing it
was like 75 tokens or something to join
at the beginning yeah which was like i
don't know exactly what it was but i
think it was more like a hundred dollars
when it started
and
now that thing is that's like a four
thousand dollar membership to join that
same because the token has appreciated
like crazy so the
the token even just since we were going
to talk about this last podcast and i
was like
hang on i'm going to talk to somebody um
who knows about the stuff let's do it in
the next episode wow it's up 46 since
this last week's and when we talked
about this
so that that means it's 68 uh 685
uh yeah so the membership is roughly
seven grand now
and uh to join
and um
you know like equinox
which is like you know a high-end gym in
in la new york sf
uh where you get to go to this like
fancy gym where it has spa steam room
members whatever equinox eco
equinox is 2 400 i think three 2 400
maybe 3 000 so this is double that now
um to get into the discord
so obviously you can tell i'm a little
bit skeptical uh just to put some more
numbers around it just to give you a
sense of how big this is so
basically this is now a 90 million
dollar market cap community
i think the founders tokens are like i
don't know exactly how much he holds but
roughly i think the guy has like 40 or
50 million dollars of his token
uh now the fun the thing that's that's
which is you know exciting but you can't
sell that's the real problem you can
technically go sell on the market but on
uniswap you can go you can go sell this
thing but
you
practically speaking if the founder
started to sell because he's like sweet
i want to bank 10 million from this
i think it would a crash the price and b
send a negative signal or as they call
in the crypto world like it's a it's a
rug pull uh you pull the rug out from
under the people who believed in you and
bought into this thing and you basically
screw them all over and so
this is like when i bought your big
clout and then you sold all your big
clout and it's like oh i'm holding
this empty bag that sam cashed out of i
bought his token i believed in him sorry
i didn't know you did that so that would
be well i don't even know if i i don't
know if i actually did buy it but uh but
plenty of people did and you know right
now on big cloud let's say i have i
think my token i have like fifty
thousand dollars of my own token
cool my current usage of bitcoin big
cloud's pretty low my my belief in like
it becoming the next big thing is you
know it started off like a long shot and
now i'd say it's a longer shot so i
would love to go sell that but
doing so would basically screw over the
people who invested in my token so i'm
not going to do it uh like i'm in it for
the long haul so i think that's the
challenge with this model is on paper
you get this big gain
but in reality
i don't know how much they're gonna how
much value they can reap out of this so
that's a high level tell me tell me some
things yeah so i'm gonna tell you why i
think this is actually incredibly
interesting friends with benefits itself
it's not that's not interesting to me um
basically if you look at it it's just
like really good looking dudes and and
ladies who are like going like and
hanging out like it's like a hip
uh young la new york type of thing i
don't really have too much faith in
those types of businesses that are
they're more jokes to me than they are
actual real businesses
um would you say that's accurate
uh why is it a joke
because i don't know if this is run like
a
like when i when i see it i'm like oh
you're just gonna run this like a like
an art project
um not necessarily like are you a party
promoter uh is this a nightclub so
either it's a fad right because the
problem with cool exclusive things is
when you try to grow them they become
less cool and less exclusive because
you're
more people in um who
you know so it comes becomes less less
tight-knit the other thing is
um
are you doing this because you want to
be a cool guy or are you doing this
because it's actually like a really
solid business underneath i think that's
kind of the other thing you're talking
about which is like my point what are
your sort of intentions with this thing
do i take it seriously or no
but
and here's the butt
so the thing about communities
communities are great companies
um the problem with them though is that
they're challenging to scale the more
people who join oftentimes the worst it
gets
that's like
that's yeah that's the law of
communities but why are you saying that
communities are great businesses i would
say communities are not great businesses
what communities do you think are great
business well let's define
these are all generalizations let's
define how we mean great when i say
great i don't mean it's really hard to
be huge huge like north of 100 north of
a billion dollars but
like they could make someone 10 to 20
million in sales a year
at a pretty good profit margin and you
can use that profit to build more stuff
so for example trends i didn't realize
it at the time but had i still owned it
or the hustle we could have turned that
into trends as a paid community we could
have turned it into an investment
vehicle to invest in cool startups
things like that and so that's why it
would it would have been great for me to
own even though it may not be huge in
itself it would have led to
opportunities and it could have been
quite profitable you know i could have
paid myself millions of dollars a year
because of it so that's my definition of
great now what's interesting about
friends with benefits is they use this
software called collab lan have you
looked at collab lan
yeah well actually they used to use a
different platform
they used to use uh
roll i think uh so roll was their old
platform then it got roll got hacked and
so all the all the tokens that were
built on all the social tokens that were
built on roll crashed uh when that
happened is i guess they switched over
to collab land so collab lantern is cool
because the thing about communities is
the more people who join
the uh sometimes the worse it gets and
so why this is interesting to me is that
people are incentivized to stay and make
the community valuable because their
value goes up even if they don't
necessarily want to sell it um well i
actually do think that like one or two
people could sell their their thing
their their token and if they want to
bail but they're incentivized to make
the community better and i think that's
a great model i really actually think
this model is amazing
so so i thought about this uh two two
different ways so let's first do
let's first do uh
let's break it into three parts there's
what is this and why is this interesting
there's how big could this be
and then there's what other could
you do like this what do you think the
future looks like so let's do what is
this and how big is it so so i would say
we we kind of explained friends benefits
it's a social token it's used to create
a membership club
the membership cost now seven thousand
dollars it's really appreciated like
crazy you know if you're friends with
benefits if you hold that token like ben
ben is a member so ben got in at like
probably 100 or a couple hundred bucks
membership
he never uses it so he's like god the
discord is super noisy like i'd have to
like really go spend time in there to
like make friends and do all the stuff
i'm too busy for all that so like i
never i basically never go in there um
but he's like it's cool because i hold
this token it's going up so i have this
like seat in the club and uh i could
sell that if i wanted to or i could use
it if i wanted to so he's like it's kind
of cool he bought it kind of like just
to
just play with the technology just to
play with like this new
experiment
so these are called social tokens the
idea is that you know any creator
any set of creators could create one of
these so you know the paul brothers i
think have had like the maverick club i
think
the milk boys have their own club and
these are just like you know traditional
you pay us a monthly subscription and
you get access to insider content so
this is basically owning instead of
renting so instead of renting your spot
in the club through a monthly fee
you own your spot in the club and
there's a limited number of spots and
then that's an asset that you could then
flip later to somebody else if you want
to get out of the club and you want
somebody else to take your spot and i
think that everyone's a lot awesome and
everyone's in line
everyone is aligned and it becomes
instead of a expense it becomes an
investment so i think that is
a switch that gets flipped right instead
of a nine nine dollars a month
okay cool i paid 900 but i own this
thing and if i was correct in betting
that like let's say we made one for my
first million right
if we if they were correct and betting
that this like let's say nine months ago
they're like oh i think this podcast is
gonna get bigger well guess what it did
and if there was only
whatever a thousand spots in our in our
private club in our private group where
we're sharing either insights deals
making introductions between people that
sort of thing it's a cute community of
people
that could be pretty valuable right like
there's a pretty strong case why we
should create one of these for
the like kind of fans of the show that
are like hardcore members right um and
then they own it and then they say all
right cool the more popular sean and sam
get the more people are gonna want to
get into this club in my thousand dollar
seat i'm gonna get value from it today
and then i might flip it for three grand
or ten grand
two years from now or a year from now
that's like the promise
yeah and and i think that's a great idea
now let me put something in perspective
so did you know that soho house went
public recently
i saw you put this here so i started
doing some research on it pretty pretty
fascinating go break it down yeah so
soho house it doesn't have to be a bad
business but it is so soho house is
basically a members only club it's
basically a country club but instead of
a golf course you get access to like a
library
feeling building like a with a bar and a
restaurant and maybe a pool maybe
sometimes they have a gym and it's
basically in new york la probably paris
london it's in where all like rich cool
young people live it costs about two
thousand or three thousand dollars a
joint depending on how old you are
and they have a hundred thousand members
and they recently went public at a three
billion dollar market cap and the reason
why their business isn't great is they
took on a lot of debt covid really hurt
them and uh i think maybe it's slightly
mismanaged but it's not a bad people
putting some numbers around that i think
they had like 900 million dollars of
debt
um from because they're buying real
estate in the most prime locations right
there they have real estate or if the
leases were owned i don't know which one
uh in like you know manhattan la uh not
san francisco around london
um
so they had 870 million i think of debt
and then during covid they furloughed
ninety percent of their workforce i
think so uh they furloughed ninety
percent of the workforce but they only
churned ten percent of members because
hey the members are kind of wealthy and
whatever and b they like offered other
perks like kind of like digital perks to
try to come up with other ideas because
you couldn't go into the building and
and do your soho house like you know
you know mingling or whatever whatever
people do at these places and so the
reason why forensic benefit interests me
is i don't care about this i don't care
about that company like i said i don't
think that they're gonna run it like a
proper company but if you were going to
i think i would do the soho house model
where i try to have buildings that are
really nice and you really want to come
and it's ran like a proper company i
would 100 do it this way that takes a
lot of risk you know like i got to make
sure that these members this the
membership stays valuable but it
incentivizes me to make my make it great
for my members and i could use some of
that money to buy buildings and i think
so
i think that i would use this model for
a soho style membership
yeah so so what do you think about us
doing it why why would you or why
wouldn't you do it
um i think that it makes a ton of sense
there's really only one reason why you
wouldn't do it which is do you want to
more work yeah
that's pretty much the only thing and
it's like the thing we were talking
about the very beginning like
reciprocity if somebody gives you a diet
coke you feel like you kind of yeah all
right cool i'll kind of hook you up
there's a as soon as somebody becomes a
member of your club you feel obligated
to make a really awesome club
you're like i will not sleep until this
club is until you feel like you're
you're getting the edge on this deal by
10x unfortunately that's the way my
personality is wired and i think you're
the same and so it's like oh good do i
want to over deliver on something right
now i don't know i gotta i gotta think
before i commit to that because yeah
before that's the only reason why you
wouldn't do it but if you wanted to run
this like a company and you wanted to
create a co-working space and you wanted
to do it with this model i think that's
a
that's a i wouldn't say easy but it's a
very interesting path to build something
quite big
yeah and i don't know if i agree with
you that he has to have a physical space
i don't really think it's that it's more
like
um
you have to have value so okay so soho
house is valuable because it's a place
you can go it's kind of like a third
place
um you can see you know you know that
everybody who else who's there is cool
so i think for this like
the idea of having a digital community a
discord slack facebook group whatever
where everybody's cool like you've seen
this with trends that's pretty valuable
people people dig that they think about
that like with trends you produce
research reports right so you're going
to get access to intel
intelligence about the market that's
interesting to you cool that that works
too
there's also other stuff like
for example i think that being able to
access deals and deal flow is like
pretty important to people um
or at least a certain set of people who
have more more sort of money than good
investments and good investment
opportunities around them
and then the last piece is
you could also do this with you could
sort of like auction off time in a way
so like
there's a world where we basically would
say all right
we create a friends with benefit token
and
with that token comes you're going to
get access to me and sam
uh like right now that token gets you
one hour with me and sam and so we
create basically a thousand booked out
bookable hours when we mint these tokens
but you also know that our time is going
to become more valuable and you want to
use it when you when it's really
important to you and so that's going to
appreciate in value over time as our you
know elon musk in 2000 his time was
easier to book than it is today today
it's basically priceless you basically
cannot pay any amount of money
there might be some huge amount of money
that you would have to pay to get an
hour of his time uh with him not getting
anything else in return and so um
something that's the other thing you
could offer a value is basically time
with
people of value and that time could be
like an investment you're basically
betting today that i want to i want to
hold a block of sam's kind of like
advice or coaching or you know just
hangout time because i think that's
going to go up in value over time
yeah so anyway it interests me um
and i agree i think we're aligned there
can i tell you about one more
interesting thing that is related to
rich people i yes so have you ever heard
of this company called wealthx
no what is it okay so every year wealthx
is wealthx is a company it's a database
company and what they do is they
basically use publicly available uh
records so property records and and
sometimes you can get people's tax
returns things like that and they look
for people who are ultra high net worth
ultra high net worth is defined as 30
million dollars in assets and they
create this massive database i believe
there's 800 to 700 000 people in the
world that are considered ultra high net
worth and all they do is they comb
through loads of different data and then
they have independent researchers who
work their hardest to verify that this
is true and the reason why i discovered
this is for years wealth x is famous
every year they put together a study
that says here's how the wealthy are
investing their assets and they create
this end-of-year asset allocation and
they say wealthy people have this much
in gold this much in real estate
whatever um and i think that this is an
interesting business and it was actually
recently acquired by a publicly traded
company so i was able to look back at
their at their numbers and i actually
think that a company like this is
shockingly easy to start and i think
this company undersold so they sold for
20 million dollars in cash they were
doing about 12 million in revenue with
800 000 in profit if i was the founder
of this company i never would have sold
they sell this to people for 15 000 or
to other companies for 15 000 a year for
subscription access and they basically
are selling it to people who manage um
people's money so um right well
financial advisors
things like this but
the interesting thing to me and the
takeaway to this if you're listening
i think this model of business this data
business we've called this um
i think we said that that messy data
wants to be free is that or sorry data
wants to be free data wants to be free
yeah data wants to be free and and and
and and um
doesn't mean free price wise it wants to
be it's like trapped and it wants to be
let free basically correct and the
founder of cb insights that does kind of
like this for publicly or for privately
held companies he told me the same thing
he goes our whole motto model motto is
uh there's a bunch of dirty
muddy data out there and we're going to
go and find it and just make it really
easy to consume that's what wealthex did
i'm just pretty certain i've read the
glasstop reviews i'm pretty certain that
this business
is amazingly easy to copy and to figure
out so the ways that they get data is
they'll they'll tell you they'll look at
who owns a jet
they'll figure out who's donating money
so if you donate money to a non-profit
oftentimes that's made public if you're
buying personal property if you have
certain hobbies if you donate get on the
list they don't know how much you have
but they're like oh sam park big
donation must have money all right put
them on the list
yeah they look at per um they look at
what so if you're part of tiger glo uh
what's it called tiger 21
if you um if you have certain interests
certain hobbies donate money that's how
they get their information it's just not
that hard to build this type of business
now right it is hard to sell but
everything's hard to sell if you're
going to get in the phones and you got
to call people you you sell some 15
grand that's always hard but
by creating the data out of your blogs i
think this is such a straightforward
business if you wanted to make some
money
um so so so they
didn't make a ton of money
and why is that so this seems like like
cb insights is a big business i don't
know i don't know what cba says what was
it worth 200 million
uh
worth that or making that
revenue
revenue yeah exactly it's worth probably
closer to a billion dollars then yeah
really more by the way founder listens
to the pod shout out to anand i think
you think he's uh he's a pretty avid
listener so
that that business worked in a much
bigger way but same principle like
you're saying right data is there it's
muddy we go dig it up we wash it off we
rinse it we polish it we package it we
say here you go here's that data you've
been looking for it was here like yeah
you could have gone and got it yourself
but man you don't want to go scrub
through that mud well let us do that for
you let us organize this whole thing so
you just type in the name you want to
know about type in the industry you want
to know about and bam here's the info
and so um that business worked why is it
is it because
financial advisors there weren't enough
of them no there's a lot of them they
weren't willing to pay for this info why
do you think this business didn't work
and what would you do differently
it probably didn't work because they
probably just hired a ton of people to
make this stuff so whenever if you go to
the website you can kind of tell some of
their technology is janky what i would
do is i would use something like
import.io or another third-party service
like that and i wouldn't build too much
technology i would only have uh my only
technology that i would build was a
pretty interface that pulls it all
together but i think you can build most
of the stuff using zapier import.io
airtable things like that i think that
you could build like a pretty robust mvp
that you could charge money for using
things like this
and so i probably didn't make money
because they probably their staff was
just a bloated staff the company was
founded in 2010 so when they launched a
lot of this technology that third party
technology wasn't available and so i
think they just have a bloated staff
that was mostly doing manual work to go
and find these types of people
um yeah okay i can see that uh this cool
service i've never actually heard of
wealth x so uh i'm gonna go read the
report i think that's that's pretty dope
uh by the way i wanna say one other
thing on the community side that we were
talking about going back um
i don't think communities are great big
businesses that's what i mean
community of communities of communities
can be great big businesses discord is a
community of communities reddit is a
community of communities and both of
those are like 10 billion
ish sized companies and so if you can
build and so that's why i actually think
collab land like if i was going to put
money somewhere and go put it in collab
land not in france with benefits
same page
the platform you're using to launch all
these different communities that has the
potential to be much bigger than any one
of these random tokens i don't know who
the is buying friends benefits
this might be a thing that they could
just manipulate themselves by the way i
have no idea i think these thinly traded
things could be uh potentially i'm
saying they did i'm just saying who the
heck is bidding up the price like this
it doesn't make a ton of sense to me um
but
but yeah my main point is that community
of communities are better businesses
than an individual one once a community
one's a technology company so my point
of bringing it up was collab land i
would rather invest in but i wouldn't i
think that you can own a community that
does 10 or 20 in sales and is profitable
but yeah you're not gonna you're not
going to knock it out the park with that
business all right what do you got
uh all right let's do another one um
let's do
uh okay i have a little like hot girl
side hustle so we've done blue collar
side hustle we've done
teenage you know the puberty side side
hustle and now this is my hot girl side
hustle so i'm just trying to identify
simple things
that anybody who's in a certain
demographic can do
that will generate you know
10 to 50 000 a month of profit without
big upfront costs or like specific hard
skills that you need to have
and i'm not going to say only fans
although that is definitely a hot girl
side hustle so this hot girl side hustle
is a little bit different
there are uh i don't know if you you
kind of follow this too much actually
you do because i think you guys run ads
like this the dominant way to advertise
for products now because you're
advertising on social networks the
dominant way to advertise is not
super high production value uh
finely produced uh content it's what we
call yeah it's selfie content right ugc
is what they call i call it selfie
because it's ugc who the knows what
that means so user generated content
basically and they're not doing
companies aren't just doing this on
social at this point if you look at a
commercial on tv for chime
it's the same thing
well yeah the digital first companies
when they go to tv like chime right
first spent 100 million dollars on
digital and now they go to their first
tv spot and their whole company has been
trained of like hey you know what works
when it just looks like a normal person
talking
because an ad people just get sort of
blind to an ad that just blaze right
over it and so what works really well
like i see this with with you guys with
morning brew which basically like
it's a tick tock ad and the person's
like
you know
my secret to getting my boss to think
i'm super smart
and then it's like i i subscribe
to the hustle and it's like that gives
me the news every morning and i look
really smart that
that that ad crashes
that tag line like so morning brew does
it the skim does it the hustle does it
um all of everyone who's in the
the email space does that you know who
invented that or who who first used that
line
no
i wrote that
i wrote that i wrote that i stole it
from an old ad book i wrote that in 2016
i think i stole it from an old ad book
of like um
something about a guy being a piano
player uh there was like a piano lesson
ad from the 1960s about being a great
piano player he goes uh he thinks i'm
naturally a great piano player i'm not i
really just use this this lesson or this
way of learning music and i took that
and i applied it here now everyone uses
it
well that's kind of genius because
that's not even like a word for word
right that's actually like quite a
different thing but you got inspired by
it yeah it's called swipe files so i
keep swipe files so um i keep uh uh
digital files of all my favorite
favorite old ads so for for example
there's this one great ad about the wall
from the wall street journal and they
it's made them like 50 million dollars
in recurring revenue and it was launched
in like the 70s and it was called like
the tale of two young men and it was
like both of these young men went to the
same college they had similar jobs um
one did this and one did that one earned
this one earned that what where the
difference one bought the wall street
journal subscription their freshman year
of college
and uh
that's like the whole the story of the
ad and like the headline is like the why
did these two young men do the almost
the exact same thing but and so so
we should run that same ad for the
podcast
and we should be like basically that one
listened to one listen to my first
million one didn't uh one became a
millionaire by 30 and the other one you
know is still still like hoping that
retirement kicks in you know at 65. uh
we should run that same ad and then we
should when you click it we should tell
the backstory of the ad basically and
it's a great story it's a great work so
i keep a file full of these types of
things so anyway go ahead by the way if
people want to see uh go to
swipefile.com our friend neville owns
swipefile.com which is a great little
domain to have and he's built like a
pretty awesome wordpress
digital swipe file i wish mine was like
that my mine is like in my notes app and
i have a slack channel that's where i
keep my swipes but like if i could i
would i would have one like that
but he's got tons of great stuff there
um
okay going back to actually this
marketing thing by the way that uh
i kind of want to give you more props
that's kind of a genius
way to market the hustle right so how
would a normal person a purchase they
would say hustle to daily newsletter so
i'm going to say sign up for our daily
newsletter get the news delivered to you
every morning right like that they would
focus on the product
and you focused on basically the happy
ending
and even the happy ending you didn't
just say and now you're informed because
that doesn't like get people emotionally
to like register at all right uh what
you're basically saying is what's the
outcome you want you want to look smart
in front of your boss you want to look
smart at work
we help you look smart at work you know
read the hustle if you want to look
smart at work you like drew this line is
that how you think about it that's how i
think about it how do you think about or
exactly what's your framework basically
um one user told me one time that they
were in a job interview for lyft and
they brought up a certain line like a
certain story at the end of an interview
that wasn't going well and that created
a relationship with this person
interviewing her and there's like okay
great i'm in this person's head we were
able to have chit chat thank you also
you made me look smart and so the idea
here is um i wanted a story
but i i only wanted to be able to tell
that story in like 200 characters and so
i believe the original ad was like my
boss thinks i'm a smart parenthesis i'm
not
um the hustle is my secret weapon to
trick them though it's working
wonderfully try it or something like
that and yeah
that was the whole idea behind behind
the ad
that's amazing that ad has reached 300
million people i think at this point
[Laughter]
yeah and then everybody copied it but
you know whatever you do what you gotta
do so uh okay what was i talking about
before this i was talking about um
oh take time okay so so uh you know what
i was trying to get to was basically
that my hot girl side hustle the one i
was trying to get to is almost all
digital advertisers have realized that
this selfie style content that looks
like native content if you're on tic tac
it's going to look like it's going to be
a funny or cute or interesting or
amazing video
or if it's on instagram it's gotta look
like an instagram post on facebook it'll
look like a facebook post those perform
better than
your professional commercials your
professional ads that look highly
polished people just skip past the
polish stuff because they're looking for
entertainment so you have to look like
the type of entertainment that looks
like that's native on the platform so
this has created a shortage
of people who can create
great on script on brand
selfie content
and so i know this for our brand but
many many brands everybody is trying to
farm this out to either influencers
or
agencies the agencies are like look we
we can run your ads but like making this
creative takes a lot of time and energy
and thought and like
we don't have actors and like a place a
nice house to do this in
so the hot girl side hustle is this
there's this girl on twitter her name
social savannah if you go look her up
she's like a kind of like a i'll help
your brand grow through facebook ads
through tick-tock ads and she's what
she's not doing or what she does some of
but it's not the important part is like
i do brand strategy i do advertising
strategy well guess what a lot of a lot
of agencies pitch that same thing we
will we will manage you we'll run your
ads we'll be your ad agency what she
does that's different is she basically
is it's her and i think she has like a
couple of other like girls with her that
do this they're like send us the product
and then we'll take a bunch of these
selfie videos and we will be the actor
in your content and because i know what
ads work i know what to say on here and
i just look like an average person and
that's why this ad is going to work
because i just look like an average
person i'm not like um
i like i have
i can make i can get somebody's
attention when they're scrolling but i
don't look like an actor in a set with a
perfe
professional camera and a professional
background i look like a girl in our
house so this is my if you're a college
student if you're a college girl
specifically there are a huge number of
brands that will pay you don't try to
become instagram famous become instagram
ad famous and what that means is
be the person who can take any product
and just do a demo a sales pitch and a
testimonial and create branded ad
content and you can charge thousands of
dollars a month
and you can charge even a percentage of
the ad spend uh for this which is kind
of insane if you're good
how much do you think flow from the
progressive commercial gets paid a year
oh my god i i don't even know if this
depends how good her agent is but you
know they're spending
tens of millions easily on that campaign
she's like a branded part of it like if
you swi if you switched out flow it'd be
like hey wait that's not flow who the
heck is that it's like uh you don't know
this but there's this children's cartoon
that's like the second most video watch
video on youtube it's called blippi have
you ever heard of blip
it's like baby shark but like blippi is
this guy and what he does is he goes
into like toy stores after they're
closed and he films a video of himself
playing with all the toys and it's like
mesmerizing for like my daughter she
can't look away when like blippi can
play for an hour it's like you're
playing with the toys you're just
watching him and then like halfway
through like the youtube channel they
just switched the guy
and all the parents are like who the
hell is this guy like this guy's you
could just switch blippi and like i
could see this
it's not like there's a new barney under
the hood it's like so kids can't tell
or at least like
at the age of my daughter she's too like
she can't tell maybe like a
four-year-old can tell or something like
that but
but the parents always have to sit there
with it and so like there's tons of
online forums where people are like uh
did you see that they tried to just
switch blippi on us like that like
whatever so basically yeah i don't know
if they can switch flow at this point
maybe they can maybe they can't like the
old spice guy the dos equis guy these
become like
part of the actual
like to become like non-fungible you
know parts of the of the
ad i think this is great for this woman
how much money thinks she should make in
this this uh what's her name
social savannah i have no idea i mean if
you told me she's making fifty to a
hundred thousand dollars a month i would
say yeah that sounds about right
if you told me she's making a little bit
less i'd say she's probably going to be
at 50 to 100 000 a month soon
why because
brands need this content i don't want to
have to arrange photo shoots or put
myself in front of the camera i just
want to send
you know product to this person once a
month and they sit there in their
bedroom and they record a new ad every
day and then i have 30 pieces of
creative at the end of the month by the
end of the month that i'm testing on
facebook and i'm saying this one works
this one doesn't do more like this
um and that's what i want
this woman is perfect
she is perfect
this is so here's why
here's why she's perfect uh she's
perfect because so i've run uh my team
had we've run eight figures in ads a lot
of ads i personally have probably ran
five million maybe eight million so like
a fair amount of um when we first
started i i ran a lot of them
and
my our podcast we've gotten accused of
being bros i'm just going to say what
i'm going to say but don't like hate me
this is just the truth okay this is just
the truth okay so we would have three
different types of ads
well actually four a hot guy
like a good-looking but not like hot
like an everyday next door type of guy
right from the office yeah the the
equivalent for a woman so like a a
pretty girl next door woman and then
like a smoking hot like traditional
yeah yeah or at least like the
stereotype of like this like you know
whatever you like
what you think a model looks like if
you're gonna make a have a model for
your brand yes
for both men and women
the pretty next door girl worked
significantly better significantly
it always works and so that shocked me
it worked amongst both men and women and
when i look at this woman i'm thinking
in my head this is she's like kind of
exactly
the the ads that that we run they look
like this woman the ones that won at
least
exactly uh that's exactly it so even
though i called it my hot girl side
hustle it's really
not a hot girl study it's actually
should be called more like the reason
actually the way i was thinking about
this was approachable
yeah girl next door side hustle
basically
and if you if you are like cute
basically that's the bar
um because you have to get somebody's
attention when they're scrolling and the
way the social media works whether
people like this or not if this is a
controversial statement like get over
yourself the way social media works is
people
um react to or they stop or they pause
when they see somebody attractive in
their feed right we're like monkeys just
scrolling through our feed and so uh so
so that's why i think you have to be
certain level of attractiveness but
really the most important part is
the thing has to look like somebody just
like posting something from their their
account not a branded thing and that
works the best so anyways i think this
is an easy way to get to five to ten
thousand dollars a month
easily and i think the upside can be a
hundred thousand dollars if you're gonna
manage a group of people like there's
some people who are on college campuses
that are smart they know how to put
other people on campus to work for them
you could easily get this to six figures
a month of income and it's almost all
profit i
i don't know this woman but we run in
the same circle so this woman i'm
looking it up now so there's a guy named
taylor holiday and i forget the other
person's name but they're listeners of
the podcast they follow both of us on
twitter and they used to run this
company called common thread collective
and i think it's just an agency right
it's just an agency
they seem like great guys and i looked
up social savannah on linkedin so her
name's savannah sanchez this woman and
she used to work at that company as a
paid manager and yep uh and i imagine
what happened when she was there was
they were like hey we got to create
these ads and then somehow it came to
like oh savannah you're like you're
you're like good looking and you're
charismatic and you're creative like
let's just use you and she was like okay
fine and then she actually kind of
learned how the business worked a little
bit while she was there and this is how
she started this agency this is amazing
i'm totally on board with this yeah it
basically unbundles the ad agency so the
ad agency does they do creative but then
when they use when they do creative they
usually farm it out to a photographer
videographer or another another creative
ad agency whatever uh they'll do media
like strategy like what's your buying
strategy how much you're gonna how are
you gonna structure your campaigns
what's your budgets et cetera uh they do
like reporting client reports all that
then they're like oh you need
to be on google facebook snapchat we'll
we'll manage all those we'll put it all
in one place for you we'll keep it all
organized and the smart thing is that
somebody just unbundled and said man the
most important part of this whole thing
is the ad creative that's also the part
where you don't have to do almost any of
the like client services and that
undifferentiated stuff and um and the
good part about this is that if you are
good at it
um it's like sandwich video where
basically you get known as the the group
to go to that's who the d2c companies go
to so i think there's like an
opportunity in that to become like the
sandwich video for for d2c and look at
the link i just sent to you in zencaster
of the people who worked there
all right let's take a look
uh
employees three employees yeah okay yeah
they all look they all fit the profile
yes
yeah i love this company
yeah exactly like if i could invest in
this company i'd be like hey great just
i don't want to not long term like give
me a monthly dividend out of this
company and i'll be very very happy i
think i'll make my money back in six
months god this is great all right you
want to do one more thing yeah let's do
one more all right all right let's do
i'll do a more high tech one okay so we
did the bro bro science one i'll give
you kind of like a a cool um technology
one so cool technology one
is
more blue-collar actually there's a
whole bunch of blue-collar jobs around
construction sites like forklifts um
whatever the big i don't even know what
they're called like tractors like the
things that dig up dirt cement trucks
whatever dude
dolly parton was did anyone email you
and say like what the your
problem
no they nobody emailed me because nobody
else knows about dolly parton either
unless unless you come from a certain
part of america no i'm just joking i
think a lot of people do know and they
were just like rolling their eyes like
how does this guy not know this um
so the the thing i was going to bring up
is on construction sites you have a lot
of these uh heavy machinery drivers
basically so drivers of forklift drivers
have cranes things like that
and these are really expensive labor
and it takes skill and it's also
dangerous right and so i think what's
going to happen is
if you just fast forward 10 20 years
from now i think all of this gets
replaced with this technology that's
it's not self-driving it's more like
self-operating um which is basically
like remote uh or what they call
tele-operated so have you ever seen a
tele-operated thing have you ever seen a
demo of this
yeah so um i forget what they're called
but basically i remember about in 2015 i
went to my friend's office aj and it was
called i cracked and he had an office in
new york and an office in san luis
obispo or sorry san francisco in new
york or something like that and he had
this like thing you know remember like a
hoverboard
like the two wheels
yeah and he had like a stick coming up
from it and then an ipad and basically
what you could do is you could use your
iphone and you could be remote and you
could have this like screen hover around
the office and you could be looking at
it from your phone and talk to people so
you can go into like different rooms
things like that and they also have them
at stores now so some stores are fully
operated by those things
yeah there's a there's a i we used to
have one at our office it was kind of
like a j nobody really used it but yeah
that was like it was like a segway but
it's like an ipad on top of it and
anybody who's not there could like roll
around the office in theory
so it's a similar sort of idea but
basically there's a set of technologies
that say hey look self-driving like full
ai that's hard and far away
but what we can do is we can basically
have a we can do kind of like a labor
arbitrage so you can have like a driver
city you know instead of being in los
angeles where labor might be expensive
you have a driver in santa fe
or a driver in the philippines doesn't
matter
and basically the driver can basically
drive and you could drive a full car so
there's like eight cameras the driver is
basically looking at it like it's a
video game like they have three monitors
the front monitor is the front
windshield the left monitors if you
looked at the left window and looked at
your rear view mirror and the right one
is the right one and basically they just
drive and like the they've gotten this
down low latency where you can have a i
can go sit in a car i've done this i sat
in a car that was being driven by
somebody at a computer somewhere else
that i had never met that i never knew
and he drove me around the parking lot
no problem parked the car and i got out
and i was like oh that's cool that's
uber but the driver's not here the
driver is a video game player somewhere
else
and um and then that gets even better
because okay that's that takes advantage
of geography right maybe i make 25 an
hour here and i can pay 12 an hour in
another city but still that's like kind
of a lot of technology and risk for just
saving you know 12 an hour so then they
go next level they say well you know we
really only need the driver when they're
at a an intersection trying to make a
left turn or trying to park
so but like on a highway or you know in
a straight road very simple stuff the
computer can just do it fascinating
super accurately so what they do is
it's like the deep sentinels like the
security company that you invest in
where one security guard monitors a
hundred different doors because for a
security guard
they only need to look when there's a
when there's a person at the door if
there's no person at the door the
screen's off
and so what deep sentinel did was smart
was they made it where like you have
like a super a super agent who instead
of just a bodyguard monitoring or
security officer monitoring one location
they can monitor 100 at a time similarly
with this technology you have things
driving
and then only when the computer is
confused or gets into a defined
situation that's like uh hey this is a
left turn we only trust humans to do
left turns right now
then it pops up on the driver's screen
the driver says great i will take over
from here they do the left turn and then
they say back to autopilot and then the
thing drives off again
and so that's called human in the loop
technology where there's it's mostly ai
but then there's a human in the loop of
doing the process
so human in the loop is super
interesting
most people view it as like a just a
band-aid like a bridge until we get to
full ai but i think there's going to be
big companies that just do human of the
loop stuff and one of the human of the
loop things that i think is going to
happen is
remote operated heavy machinery on
construction sites
because if you take the people away you
reduce a lot of the danger
you reduce the skill requirement and
then maybe you you only need an operator
to do certain high skill tasks and they
just like basically load in like a video
game they do the task and then they
leave and then they go do it again so
one driver can be like
working on 10 construction sites every
day i think that's going to be pretty
cool because that person will make
they'll make three times more what's
that somebody down there
so there's a couple different companies
that are doing this there's some that
are doing this with
uh construction i don't know their names
then there's a company that's just doing
teletelly operation as a service
so basically it says hey you want to you
want to create a company doing
tele-operated forklifts cool
um or cranes great
put our kit on your on your crane and
it'll work put our software kit wow this
is this is what your driver sitting
somewhere else is going to use is our
our camera kit basically
um and that's a company called
i want to say it's like shadow or
something let me see that's pretty great
as a service
um phantom phantom dot auto is a is one
of the companies now i don't i've heard
some you know mixed things i don't know
if it's a great company this is a former
yc partner left to go start this they
raised a bunch of money who uh they're
trying to do it for self-driving cars
um
what do you say who who
uh i gotta look him up phantom auto
founder and what were the mixed things
uh well some people are just like you
know anybody who's gonna do this they
end up building this in-house they don't
actually
like self-driving is
you have so many engineers you're
working on this so hard and your
your use case might be different and so
uh they're skeptical that a third party
can provide the software that every one
of these companies going to use because
it's not like there's going to be
millions of companies that need this
it's more like dozens of companies today
that need this and all dozens of those
companies are probably going to do this
in-house
um want to say phantom was done by the
ycga maybe it's something else but maybe
i'm thinking maybe i'm mixing up two of
these
no i think i think i'm mixing up two of
these there was a different yc founder
doing this
so really quick there's this company
called winner winner so winner winner
dot com have you ever been there
yep
uh
i've checked it out but explain it
because it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool so joe spicer you know our friend
he's
uh maybe a co-founder or helped get it
going but basically what they do is they
have a warehouse in las vegas well so
how cheap is a las vegas warehouse you
would know more than i do do you know
i mean it's dirt cheap
so like you could have like i think
ramon had a massive like many tens of
thousands of square feet for like 20
grand a month and then these guys so
these guys rented this massive warehouse
and then they filled it with claw
machines and you could play
a claw machine like you see the camera
there's a camera on it and you could
play this claw machine uh virtually from
your phone and then when you pull a gift
i actually don't know
you've done it what happens when you win
a gift
they'll mail it to you so like you
basically you buy credits and then you
like play the thing and then if you win
the toy you can uh you can basically
like
pay i think you i think you have to be
at a certain level to get the free
shipping but otherwise you like pay to
have the the toy shipped to you and so
it's
it's a it's an arcade you can play from
far away and it's a tele-operated little
claw that goes down and picks up the
items it sounds silly but these are
actually really popular games uh both in
the u.s but also in japan i think this
is like a pretty big market for this
either in korea or japan and then winner
winner their numbers were pretty like
decent as well like they're doing
they're doing very well i think you guys
invested right
no we haven't but they're thinking about
we don't know if there's going to be a
a um conflict of interest we're trying
to figure it out but they're investible
you know like it's getting to that size
yeah it's it's a really cool concept uh
it's definitely worth like playing with
once just to see it kind of like
makes you think more is possible than
you thought of right like it's kind of a
crazy idea to be like hey
you know that little like two dollar
thing where you can like maybe win an
iphone or like a stuffed animal like
yeah what if you could just play that
from your phone
i don't think this was that hard to set
up either like no i don't think it's
either they say like
because little things do matter like
latency or like if i push right and it
doesn't go right
until like it lags but by then i push
right three more times now it goes right
three times and i'm like you can easily
just
get frustrated throw your phone and be
like this is stupid so there's
definitely some tech you have to do to
smoothen that out but that's getting
better and better every day and um
you know
any any group of smart people can solve
that that's a lot
easier than you know self-driving cars
or whatever but i think this whole space
to watch is tele operation remote
operation remote drivers remote arcade
games remote you know construction
remote cleaning
there's a whole bunch of things where
the machine can do 80 of the stuff the
machine can't do the last 20
so instead of just waiting until the
machine is perfect you say cool
we're going to put a human in the loop
the human will take over when that 20
needs to be done when a decision needs
to be made when an adjustment needs to
be done or whatever
and then the machine goes back to doing
it and now you have humans that are
working remotely they make more money
than they would if they were just
working on one site
and the cost of the thing goes down too
because you don't need so many humans
working on stuff to make it work so i
think it's like a win-win-win that's
going to be more popular but people
don't really talk about that today
do you follow do you know how much on it
sold for you know on it
yeah joe rogan's like thing uh you had
told me something they sold for
a couple hundred million right dude
someone told me like 200 million dollars
right
is that crazy so on its own by this guy
named aubry marcus do you follow him on
instagram
no should i
this guy is nuts i've heard some crazy
stories about this guy like i don't meta
when i say nuts i don't i think he's a
fine guy um but he's just like an
oddball i've heard some stories about
him that basically one time he went to
uh this uh rural area and went into an
isolation
area but it wasn't like an isolation
tank it was like a um
a room
with no
sound or no uh
light and he stayed there for like four
or five days i've heard other stories
about how he goes to this area it does
massive amounts of lsd i've heard
stories about how he had an open
relationship with his wife and it didn't
work out and she was like i believe her
name's whitney i think she's like a
former miss america something like that
and they had an open relationship this
guy is wild if you follow him on on
instagram and he's like he's like a hunk
like he's like looks really good looking
like he's good-looking and he like heard
the word hunk in a long time dude he's
like a hunk he's like ripped he's huge
he's good-looking he's got like cool
tattoos this guy you got to follow this
guy i did script it's wild this is like
some weird i'm watching him i'm
watching him work out with a steel mace
yeah that's what they said warriors used
to use and there's like videos of him
with like war paint on and then um this
guy he this is the most this guy's so
fascinating to me
i love the founders of all these
companies so like if you want to see
interesting founders look at the
founders of supplement companies
um you know like energy drink companies
like go look at the guy from bang energy
dude tell me that's not a good time tell
me that's not a good time on instagram
go look at the guys who do supplements
uh the energy guy is like legit weird
yeah all these guys are legit weird dude
and that doesn't mean like it's not a
bad thing but they're not
you know
they're not like you know some corporate
they run big corporations but they're
not corporate they are not buttoned up
they are uh they're a little wild
yeah man this is a good follow you got
to follow aubrey marcus he like he does
all this spiritual stuff like there's
here's a video of him um he's getting um
like blessed by a spiritual shaman or
something i don't even understand like
some of this terminology um and
all right i have a good follow for you
too on instagram of a tech founder do
you follow the founder of telegram
powell
no is he is he a nutty
okay so we just type in p-a-v-e-l he's
the ceo of telegram yeah
telegram if you don't know it telegram
is basically whatsapp but it's made by
this kind of like guy who's
he won't sell the company so he's like
you know
this guy's actually kind of like a
genius i think he started vk which is
the the russian facebook it's the only
country
d-u-r-o-v
uh and his handle is just
d-u-r-o-v yeah i got him
so so this guy's story is pretty nuts uh
so he starts vk naomi
vk is the uh the russian facebook
facebook the facebook basically has
taken over every other like oh i'm
facebook for brazil it was like orc no
facebook comes wins it's like oh i'm
facebook for like bibo bibo was facebook
and ireland in the uk and in australia
boom facebook won
and then in russia they just could never
beat vk for like a combination of like
slightly political reasons but also
i've seen interviews with zuckerberg
where he's like dude they're engineers
these are like the most brilliant
mathematicians ever and they've just
made it their mission in life as soon as
we release anything they haven't copied
in 24 hours like it's and it's like
pixel for pixel copy so vk is facebook
but instead of blue it's red
it's like a pixel for pixel copy of
facebook but it's red and it it has
withstood facebook facebook has not been
able to win
in russia even after like all this time
but then
you know putin or whoever the government
there they basically took over vk they
just like took over the company and like
demanded certain things he refused and
so this guy had to flee the country so
this guy flees
and he creates telegram which is this
like ideal this is like encrypted
messaging app
and it's like whatsapp but it's uh not
owned by facebook so a lot of people
like it i love it it's great product
um
and he basically self-funded it for a
long time like he's put like 50 million
of his own money into like doing he's
like there's no ads there's no whatever
and then he made a bunch of money when
they did an ico a token sale but they
never actually went through with it but
they got free money for a while from
that uh but this dude's instagram
following is hilarious
you'll never see anyone else in his
instagram feed no friend no girlfriend
boyfriend wife kid nothing it's only him
it's usually him with no shirt on and
he's pretty ripped and he's
he's very ripped i mean he looks like
first
he
is always doing like model-esque photo
shoots dude he's like vito
he's like sitting on a sand dune or he's
like riding a horse into the sunset like
he's in a speedo under a waterfall
and uh this guy is just hilarious to
follow i just find this guy to be like
an actual character no he's
36 years old worth 20 billion dollars
and he's got like pictures of him like
with this mega yeah this guy's
fascinating i'm gonna i'm gonna
successfully this is the billy of the
week pavel pavel you are the billy of
the week so where's he live
just for he floats around he doesn't
tell anyone where he lives he's in dubai
a lot
but he travels around and he doesn't he
can't go back to russia
and he can't go he can't go back to the
state he can't come to the states
doesn't want to come to the states
and so he just goes to like you know
beautiful places that are you know
uh i don't know if he lives in one place
he's just like always traveling it's him
sometimes in the u.s sometimes in dubai
finland brazil wherever paris and then
uh he runs the company sort of like
remotely so wikipedia says i don't know
this word um aesthetic like what's that
mean aesthetic i guess that means you
don't know own much and he
won't give up your possessions he
promotes freedom of property so i guess
he doesn't own uh that much stuff
yeah wow
yeah he ran some nice i'll tell you
that much so
he's renting like a like a mega yeah
probably a 100 million dollar yacht this
guy's fascinating and his kind of like
mission in life is just sort of to be
like the anti-facebook anti-vk
um
and so i find him to be cool because
he's like an idealist like if you use
telegram he writes the update and he'll
be like
we have you know 10 million more members
uh telegram remains 100 free 100
encrypted 100
uh you know like um
uh what's it called like you know
independent and he's like you know we
release these new features and he's just
like he definitely has like an
idealistic streak around privacy yeah
around freedom at least that's what he
promotes and this company is like a 20
billion dollar company right
or like a multi-billion dollar startup
telegram would be a multi-billion dollar
startup but again there's no there's no
outside investors and there's no uh
he'll never sell so you know it's
nobody knows the real value this might
be one of the most valuable companies
per employee i'm looking at their jobs
page they only have like five jobs up a
content moderator a translator a
translator a junior accountant an
assistant to the ceo
dude that's a sick job if you can become
an assistant if paul's a ceo that's a
sick job
that's crazy right
yeah what's that interesting company
does it make money
uh no it doesn't make any money
he doesn't care about it making money he
doesn't want it to make money they did
they were like pretty pure until they
did this ico thing they basically did
yeah yeah they were like we're going to
beat ethereum we're going to like build
a better version of ethereum
uh with all this crazy they
released this white paper that was like
we are solving all these impossible
computer science things and people who
were smart technically they were like
all right well like if anyone's gonna do
it it's gonna be these guys but i don't
think i don't think anybody can do this
and definitely nobody can do this in
this timeline that they're talking about
um like the crazy sharding schemes or
whatever and basically they um
so so
so they did this ico i think they raised
like four billion dollars or three
billion dollars i have some of the
details wrong i never i didn't prepare
for this one but they raised a few
billion dollars and then the u.s
basically said
you yeah you can't that's a security
offering you can't do that unless you
follow these regulations and so they
just pulled the plug on the ico but for
a year they held everyone's money saying
it's going to get listed at the end of
the year or two years maybe even they
helped everybody
so they had like a free float of a
multi-billion dollar float for multiple
years and then they gave back the money
but for the deal was so hard to get into
that all these middlemen who had
allocation i think you had to buy 20
million dollar slots uh that was like
the minimum purchase at the time i think
people would buy the 20 million and then
they would sell chunks of it to
individual retail investors like me
for 30 million a 40 million total and so
people got back the 20 million but if
they sold it for more than that initial
strike price
you were screwed so a lot of people put
in you know a hundred thousand dollars
into this thing and got back 70 two
years later um you know but that's the
risk you take i'm gonna be researching
this all day
um yeah that's the episode i gotta run
cool all right see you later
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back